my next guest who's sitting here to my
right that'll be seen every single
Wednesday at 10 p.m. on audience DirecTV
channel 239 and DirecTV now starting
tonight max irons good to see you sir
you four have what a great movie this is
thank so for you to be part of this
television reboot playing the Robert
Redford character yeah how for those who
are familiar with three days of the
Condor how close to the character that
we've known from Redford are you
portraying you know we had a rule on set
that you want to allow a Robert
Redford's name they did not know that it
was 100 bucks if you said it okay I
needed the cash machine thankfully
there's one across the way here in a
thoroughfare at AT&T yeah
no the truth of it was you know Robert
Redford is one of the most charismatic
fondly remembered handsome you know
everything you could throw at him actors
out there so I watched the film I
watched it a couple of times in fact and
then there was a screening the night
before we started filming okay you know
everyone's gonna show up and watch the
movie and celebrate the movie and I
thought no I can't do this I think you
know at some point you you you take what
you can sure you acknowledge you value
appreciate and then you sort of have to
let it go and then try not to worry
about it too much because otherwise
having Robert Redford you know leaning
over your shoulders overwhelming yeah
yeah I imagine so so was there really a
rule on set that anyway I just want to
make sure that's next season Thanks well
I'm sick of it well that you just put it
in your contract you put it in your
writer one of those lines at the bottom
line right so seeing this tonight is the
premiere here in Los Angeles and seeing
the film as you did and now having taken
part in this how do you like the
finished product max well I think you
know when the film came out in 1975 I
think it was particularly relevant with
the backdrop of you know Richard Nixon
you got Watergate you've got it you've
got the citizenry who were becoming
suspicious of their governmental bodies
acting in their best interest and I
think that is a theme is timeless but is
particularly relevant today you know we
have government bodies promising they're
acting on in our best interests and in
fact proven to be not
and upon closer inspection of the CIA
and what they've done over the past 75
years a lot of the decisions they've
made have in fact not necessarily been
in the interest of the American people
so that's their the themes we explore in
condo and I think it's as relevant today
as it was then max irons here on the
Rich Eisen show are you a fan of
football as it is known outside of the
United States in any ways you know what
I was sitting over there listening to
you guys discussing what I assume is
football yes none of it made sense
national football not even one small
phrase within a sentence medicine but at
least we are aware or some of us here in
this country that that football as we
know it is called soccer here as it's
known football around the rest of the
world so hang on are you asking me about
your football and your soccer yes that's
the one I know nothing about either
[Music]
world cup I can leave no whatsoever to
left feet milk you never even tried it
at all I tried it okay a rugby I don't
know if you're familiar with that game
okay that's a great game well we could
see them the show that you can run we
see that you know that's nice of you
because I wasn't so certain about my
right is that right did you have to work
on that safe to say I could have done
more work I I think I think I have a
very English style of run something up
right too much elbow and me is that
right cause I was gonna say you've got a
very Redford like gait is that okay I
mean I know I don't want to I don't want
to I don't want to spend I'm already 300
dollars in the hole now based on your
ear Redford rule right now like game of
Redford like you've made my week you
know I do want to ask you this cuz
obviously we can hear from your your
accent that you are not American but you
cannot tell when you are watching Condor
so it's a nice thing nor the cable is
what I do for a living this is uh no so
how do you do that I mean I mean is
there somebody that you hear well
speaking American I guess is the only
way to put it in that regard well I I
had an accent coach he's known a
particularly interesting on
um okay I did have a couple of case
studies a couple of American actors who
I was kind of trying to 0 I went on okay
who's that I unfortunately that name
escapes me right this model you
seriously come to me in two seconds but
yeah who's this person in do you have
that okay so it'll come to me it's
somewhere in the back of my brain but
lots and lots of repetition okay that's
that's what it is there just a certain
way that uh we say a certain letter or
certain ah ah okay so now scan you say
the letter R R it's like you say ah we
say ah ah and you're like I mean I say R
R which so muscular
you know it's like cause you guys have
these big American muscle cars and we
have these little dainty little tiny
bits okay same as the language so you
out you drive those cars you drive the
car but I Drive a car damn straight I
Drive a car damn straight back science I
drive a car
interesting okay and so because it's
it's amazing sometimes how many actors
and actresses who are not from America
speak and it sounds remarkable in that
regard
oh well that's all the time and it's
nice pretty cool man thank and so did
somebody have to teach you to run
American did you have a running coach no
I just did my own work on a treadmill
believe it or not um
I have I did watch the work of Tom
Cruise but he has an inherent advantage
over me in that he's a little smaller so
he can really pump those limbs faster
and it has a sort of a more compelling
look to it than me
okay I'm 6 4 3 I'm slightly less
aerodynamic hmm so that's more upright
yeah cuz in our football mm-hmm if you
run upright yeah that's somebody of your
size right you are going to get killed
yes just letting you know for the next
role if you look can I be your your
American football coach if you ever
choose a a sports can you start now I
mean I'm very keen well just if you
could see the show logo across the way
right there you could see I am in fact
Ron
oh and you you have a wonderful gauge
well I appreciate that it's called
Photoshop oh yeah because the right leg
that's that's getting ready to plant
right there uh-huh
in the original photograph was flailed
all the way out yeah okay and a unseemly
type of gate right um I have to imagine
not you I asked them I appreciate that
an axe look at us complementing each
other hopefully I'll go $100 less but
you know the leg I had to move it in
good good work don't you think I had my
people as long as you don't tell your
audience mmm just do it on the sly so
max irons you play the role of Joe
Turner Joe Turner Turner Turner say Joe
Turner yes who if this was across the
pond yeah I'm sorry to use that phrase
Emma's an American sports guess we
always have to say that about Wimbledon
it's played across the pond
if anything happens in Australia I'm
mandated to call it something Down Under
oh yeah yeah yeah what Down Under Down
Under that's very good and then what can
you tell folks about this show that
starts again tonight that they can
expect and the reason why they should
tune in other than the fact that we're
talking about here on audio well I think
to put it really simply it's it's a very
culturally relevant fast-paced
relentlessly fast-paced runner we also a
complemented by an incredible cast we we
have William Hurt we have Bob Balaban we
have Brendan Fraser delivering a
terrifying performance in a way that
you've never seen Brendan Fraser
we have Mira Sorvino we have leme Lu
Bonnie who was an Israeli actress who's
taking max von sydow part from the movie
I'm doing a incredible job with it
and as I mentioned earlier I think it
also it what I like particularly about
the show is not only the quality of the
writing which is very high but it asks a
lot of questions of the audience you
know I think we we exist here in America
and in Western Europe and in Canada we a
fortunate have access to a lot of
luxuries for example a cheap accessible
fuel for our cars or season round food
or cell phones in our pockets and do
extraordinary things but we trade off
certain things in the case of cellphones
certain civil liberties in the in the
case of cheap accessible gas for our
cars there are certain wars in the
Middle East which make that possible or
pesticides on our food but we often turn
away from the realities of these things
to guarantee these luxuries I think what
Condor does in this instance makes us
look at national security and makes us
look at what we trade off versus what we
get for that trade and I think that's an
interesting question that we should be
asking especially as we move forward
technologically with regards to national
security and that debuts right here on
audience tonight channel 239 DirecTV
could check it out on DirecTV now 10:00
p.m. Eastern every single Wednesday
William Hurt Mira Sorvino Brendan Fraser
as you said we've never seen him before
in Bob Balaban who's been in everything
everything Seinfeld yeah especially he's
the most fiercely intelligent people
I've ever come across is that right yeah
he's frightening nice mom huh yeah one
of those people that makes you feel very
stupid very quickly okay well you
described one person here accurately and
two people as well accurately with those
phrases but fiercely intelligent or
something like that
that's fantastic premieres tonight at
10:00 p.m. Eastern on audience for the
television side of things please stay
right there max we're about to show a
clip I appreciate you coming on thank
you so much for having max irons check
him out in Condor when we come back here
on the radio television simulcast that
Ryan shazier soundbite that you promised
Chris brought when we have turned that
around as they say into television
business that's still to come along with
Luke Cage himself Mike Colter here the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience